من
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى في
رياضه في الباب
باب الاخلاص واحضار النيه في جميع الاعمال
والاقوال والاحوال البارزه والخفيه
وعن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه ابو هريره عبد
الرحمن بن صخر الدوسي رضي الله عنه
توفي اسلم في عام خيبر
وتوفي في سنه 59
قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم وتقدمت
اي ترجمته
بعض العلماء يذكر في كنيته
ابو هريره ذس كنيا ابو هريره
something that was nicknamed with
because ofent
or is this name act name as mentioned
before
many of the schar of had hold the view
that is his act name
and
one of the most notable scholars that
hold that opinion
شيخ مشايخي
الشيخ الوادعي رحمه الله تعالى
حديث
was
ابو هريره was name
are some
are mentioned
regarding how
‏said in
a coule of narrations that have some
questionable ofation
but are often mention by
said I had a small becauseيره
تصغير له او هره تصغير
صيغه
‏small
cat
small cat and so he mentions that I had
a small cat with me and in one wording
of the narration I had it in my I had it
in my sleeve right he was carrying it
around and the prophet
saw this and he said ابو هريره
انت ابو هريره
oftimes
however many sch theation toentic
way why i now you know sometimes when
these stories are not mentioned where
you think they should be mentioned then
you get bombed after the clas
‏because
I want to just because
it's not particularly authentic however
he did not
and most of the schar are the view that
name is
ابنخر
خيبر
صلى الله عليه وسلم قال قال رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم صلاه الرجل في جماعه تزيد
على صلاته في سوقه وبيته بضعا و2 درجه
كلمه بضع بضع بكسر الباء بضع في لغه العرب
في العاده تدل على ما بين الثلاثه الى
التسعه يقولون بضع وكذا يعني
شيء وكذا قل بضع وشر يعني ثلاثه او خمسه
او اربعه او سته او عش او 29 و يعني 20
وكسر
وهذه الصيغه مجمله في بعض الروايات 25 وفي
بعض الروايات 27 فكلها غير متنافيه لماذا؟
لان الذي يذكر ال 25 هو موافق لل 27 من
باب اولى متوافقون على الادنى من الرقمين
والذي يقول بضع فيقصد هذا وهذا يقول
صلاه رجل في جماعه يعني في المسجد تزيد
على صلاته في سوقه السوق في سوقه يعني في
السوق لماذا سمي سوقا قيل لان الناس
يسوقون
اي بضاعتهم الى اليه سوقا يسوقون
وقيل لان الناس يقفون في الاسواق على
ساقهم
فقيل سوقا
يقول في سوقه
وبيته بضعا و درجه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابو هريره
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان جماج
‏to
in mar
in home
by
20 some levels or by 20 some times. ‏So
notice here how he mentions 20 sometimes
meaning more than 20 times that's what
it translates to and in some
narrations it's mentioned 25 times and
others 27
times. ‏And so
he says here
that a person's prayer he said
a man's prayer a man's prayer
does this not apply to women
does this not apply to women the answer
is perhs the reward however a is
notigated to make
‏andable
un certain requirements are met unless
certain requirements are met
when we start speaking about preferable
and unpreable with regards to women
attending thejid in a place America
where we live as a minority among the
majority of non-mlims it's important
that we have facilities
‏our s because
place come toay
place
isally a of ourl country
a micm
of our contr musl environ that we cann
find elsewh where there is knowledge
available there ‏is companionship etc
and so the dynic is a b different and
the of a attending thej is more
important arguably much more important
than in a musl country where could find
alternatives however
this does not mean that the turns into a
rotary club and it does not mean that
the requirements are not for a to attend
صلى الله عليه وسلم
that
perf
[Silence]
غنا
البيهقي الكبرى رحمه الله
‏et are
when attending the however
being we have
our sister
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
الصحيح
لا لا تمنعوا ايماء الله مساجد الله
من الصحيح
الله
[Silence]
ابن عمر
بلال
لا تمنعوا الله مساجد الله
ابن عمر بلال
والله لنعهن
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عائشه رضي الله عنها ساد الصحيح
لو علم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ما فعلت
النساء
من بعده لمنعه
propet صلى الله عليه وسلم
what did after death in their attendance
of the meaning of not dressing properly
of wearing perf of etc the reasons for
going to thej the the back biting the
rors the the kinds of discussions the
kind of things that take
ابن عمر
والله لنعهن
اقول لك قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا تمنعواء الله مساجد الله وتقول لي
والله لنمنعهن
لا كلمتك ابدا
وما
حتى مات
ابن عمر
الله
[Silence]
what
is that extreme no
is not about
‏was
not someone
will have some calls himself my
disagrees with the messenger of Allah
this was this was a lesson that he is
teaching to his
رضي الله عنه
ان شاء الله تعالى والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين وجزاكم
الله خيرا